[Müzik]
Bundan yıllar önce henüz doğmamış olan
oğlumun annesi sabah karşı beni
uyandırdı kalk dedi
müstakbel oldum annesinin karnında deli
gibi tepiniyordu
Ne oldu dedim Meğer sabaha karşı
acıkıyormuş her sabah Daha sonra da
ancak bir şeyler yerse sakinleşiyormuş
Yoksa öbür türlü sakinleşmiyormuş
gerçekten de gitti bir şeyler yedi Biraz
sonra olan uykuya daldı içeride
bu bilimsel anlamda benim için zaten
enteresan bir gözlemdi ama daha da
enteresan olanı Bir İnsan yedisinde
neyse yetmişinde de değişmiyor fetüs
anne karnında sürekli iletişim
halindedir onun ilk iletişim biçimi de
dokunarak iletişim kurmaktadır fetüs
annesinin sürekli kontrol eder anne
hareketsiz kaldığı zaman Tedirgin olur
Çünkü Muhtemelen anne ölmüş de olabilir
ve onun hayatta kalması için en önemli
şey annesinin de hayatta olmasıdır O
yüzden içeride deli gibi tepemeye başlar
ta ki annesi rahatsız oluncaya kadar
hareketlenen ayağa kalkıncaya kadar Eğer
anne ayağa kalkmışsa sorun yoktur
rahatlar ve uyumaya devam eder anne de
aslına bakarsanız Gün içinde sürekli
böyle eliyle karnın yoklar ve fetüsünü
kontrol eder çünkü hamile bir geçirenler
bilirler işte hareketsizlik anne içinde
Tedirgin edici bir durumdur ve o yüzden
de sürekli şimdi şeyin fetüsün
canlılarını kontrol eder eliyle
ısıttıkça fetüs içeriden bunu fark eden
ve eliyle ve patilerini ayaklarıyla
sürekli ona dokunur Bu sayede
karşılıklı bir iletişimi ilkbahada
kurmuş olurlar
9 ay 10 gün sonra Ortalama olarak
bebek dünyaya gelir ama insan yavrusu
son derece Zayıftır bu doğum esnasında
Çünkü ne Maymun yavrusu gibi doğar
doğmaz annesinin kürküne sarılabilir ve
onunla beraber hareket edebilir ne de
ceylan yavrusu gibi doğar doğmaz ayağa
kalkıp işte Yarım saat içerisinde
annesiyle beraber yırtıcılardan
kaçabilir O da kendine özgü bir iletişim
biçimi geliştirmiştir bebek doğar doğmaz
çığlık çığlığa ağlamaya başlar Bu Hem
onun ciğerlerinin çalıştığını ve hayatta
olduğunun göstergesidir ama aynı zamanda
anneye yavrusuyla ilgilenmesi için
sağlam bir mesaj vermektedir o Çünkü çok
zayıftır ve anne sevgisi ne ihtiyacı var
buna Biz iletişimde sözsüz iletişimle
Daha doğrusu dil Ötesi unsurlar diyoruz
ne demek dil Ötesi unsurlar yani ağızdan
çıkan kelimeler haricindeki tüm seslere
Biz dil Ötesi unsurlar diyoruz mesela
yetişkinlerde bir yemeği beğendikleri
zaman şeklinde sesler çıkartabiliyorlar
ya da yalan söylemeye hazırlanırken
cevaplar gecikebiliyor
şeklinde bunlara da yine biz dil Ötesi
unsurlar adını veriyoruz bebek çığlık
çığlığa ağlayarak hayata başlamıştır
Elbette bu onun ilk mesajıdır aynı
zamanda bebekler doğdukları anda
görebildikleri mesafe 40 santimdir Bu da
annesinin kucağındaki bir Bebeğin
Anneyle göz teması kurmasına yetecek
kadardır bebek Çünkü annesinin gözlerine
odaklanmak üzere programlanmıştır hani
ne ilgisini bakımının devamını bu
şekilde sağlar O yüzden bakışlar son
derece önemlidir onun ilk
iletişim kurma biçimlerinden bir
tanesidir bakışlar öylesine ilginçtir ki
insanlar sevdikleri şeylere daha fazla
bakarken sevdikleri insanlarla daha
fazla göz teması kurarken sevmedikleri
hoşlanmadıkları kişilerle daha az göz
teması kurarlar Yani bu özellikle
hoşlanmanın boyutunu gösteren bir durum
yani Karşınızdaki kişinin sizi ilgisini
merak ediyorsanız onun bakış miktarını
test ederek oradan anlayabilirsiniz
Tabii şu da var burada kişinin gözüne
dik dik bakıp tehditkar bakışlar
savunmak Bunun elbette dışında sığınması
gereken bir konu işin ilginç tarafı göz
bebekleri de aslında bunun dışarısında
değildir
şimdi göz bebekleri ile ilgili enteresan
bir konu var
gözbebekleri aynı bakışlar gibi insanlar
hoşlandıkları kişileri beğendikleri
şeyleri hoşlarına giden şeyleri gözlükçe
göz bebekleri irileşir beğenmedikleri
hoşlanmadıkları kişiler ya da şeyleri
gördükçe göz bebekleri küçülür
bu cinsel anlamda hoşlanmalar içinde
geçerli insanlar cinsel anlamda
hoşlandıkları kişileri gördükleri
zamanda göz bebekleri büyümektedir daha
farklı bir konu var
erkekler göz bebekleri iri olan
kadınlardan
bilinçaltında Tabii ki Net bir sebep
veremesek de daha fazla hoşlanmaktadır
hatta Bunun geçmişi dönemlerde uzak
çağlarda kadınlar dul avrat otu diye bir
otun özünü kullanarak göz bebeklerini
büyüttüklerini bazı eserlerden Biz
biliyoruz Şimdi burada da böyle bir
çalışma yapılıyor Bu kadın birebir aynı
Tabii ki fotoğrafa bir numaranın göz
bebekleri belli belirsiz bir şekilde
büyütüyor ve yapılan çalışma
sonuçlarında da bir numaradaki kadının
daha fazla tercih edildiği daha çok
beğenildiği de ortaya konulmuş Yani eğer
bir popülonometreniz varsa ya da
Karşınızdaki kişinin göz bebeklerini
görüyorsanız ilişkiye dair çok daha
derin
kabuller ortaya koyabilirsiniz
tahminlerde de kullanabilirsiniz
anne karnında bazı beden dili
hareketleri bazı hareketler
geliştiriyoruz ki bu aslında Ömür boyu
da devam eden davranış biçimleri olarak
ortaya çıkıyor fetüs anne karnında sık
sık ağzı elini ağzına sokma eğiliminde
parmakların ağzına sokma eğiliminde
Çünkü bu o fetüsü o içerideyken
rahatlamasını sağlıyor Üstelik doğduktan
sonra da bu hareket devam ediyor
yetişkinler için de aslında bu istenen
bir durum Çünkü ağzı parmak sokmak
endorfin salgılanmasını mutluluk
hormonunu salgılanmasında faydalı bir
yöntem ama tabii ki Bir yetişkinin
ağzında parmakla falan dolaşması
beklenebilir bir şey değil Örneğin Bunun
yerine sigara içme sakız çiğneme tırnak
yeme ya da ağzının içerisinde kalem
gezdirme gibi bazı davranışlar
yapılabiliyor Ben mesela genelde bu
tırnaklarımın kenarındaki etli kısımları
Sitesi altındayken ısırıyorum sonra da
çok canım acıyor ya da mesela
Afganistan'da beraber çalıştığımız Şimdi
emekli olan General nickles'ın ele
alalım Bu sert görünüşlü adam karargahta
mesela Böyle sıkıntılı bir durum
olduğunda ağzının içerisine bir kalem
alır haberi dolaştırırdı ağzından
içerisinde Demek ki o da belki de bir
anne huzuru arıyordu Kabil'in ortasında
şuna beraber bakalım
baktığınız zaman sevimli mi
cana yakın
tatlı Peki içimize sokasınız geliyor mu
sarılmak geliyor mu böyle bir
koruma hissi geliyor mu özellikle
annelere de sormak istiyorum Bu konuda
Neden acaba biraz bu konuyu irdelemek
isterim şimdi
Kurbağalar için Kurbağalar için suyun
yüzeyinde hareket eden Her şey bir avdır
aslına bakarsanız Bu sinek olabilir
böcek olabilir bunu gördüğü zaman
duraksamadan dilini uzatır ve yakalar
Üstelik gerçek anlamda av olmayan yani
Mesela sahte sineklere vesairelere de bu
şekilde dilini uzatıp yakalamaktadır bu
iş duraksamadan yapar çünkü buna göre
programlanmıştır buna Biz doğuştan
tetikleme mekanizması adı veriyoruz yani
onu gördüğü zaman bu hareket otomatikman
kendiliğinden ortaya çıkıyor mesela
erkek dikenli çöl kertenkelesi içinde
mavi çizgiler erkek göstergesidir ve
yanına mavi çizgili kertenkele geldiğini
bir rekabetesinden dolayı doğrudan
saldırır
Üstelik bunu yapay olarak boyanmış
kertenkeleler içinde aynı şekilde
yapmaktadır Çünkü bu da onun doğuştan
tetikleme mekanizmasıdır Peki buraya
niye geldin
bütün canlıların yavruları hemen hemen
birbirine benzer bakın geniş bir alın
iri iri gözler küçük bir burun küçük bir
ağız değil mi küçük bir çene vücuda göre
daha kocaman bir kafa yani burada bizim
arkadaşlarımız tabii böyle bir kurgu
yaptılar ama yani gerçek anlamda
bunların her biri birbirine
benzemektedir bebeksi görünüm sonuç
itibariyle bizlere Aslında bebeklerin ne
kadar korumasız ne kadar bakıma muhtaç
olduğunu göstermektedir ve bu özellikle
insan yavrusu gibi bakıma muhtaç olan
yavruların özellikle annelerinde böyle
bir bakımışı ortaya çıkartır nasıl bir
bakım daha önce Bu zaten var olan
davranışı ortaya çıkartan bir tetikleme
mekanizmasıdır bunu gördüğü zaman bu yüz
bir biçiminden dolayı bebek
özelliklerden dolayı anne yavrusuna
bakmaya devam eder Yani aslına
bakarsanız belki Benjamin Button gibi
yetişkinler olarak doğsaydı bebekler
Belki de bu mekanizma tetiklenmeyecekti
Belki de turların devamını
sağlanamayacaktı Muhtemelen türün
devamında Aslında sağlayan bu bebeksi
görünüm olarak ortaya konulabilir
Üstelik bu çok enteresan çok farklı
yerlerde de tezahürü var mesela Amazon
Nehri kıyısında yaşayan Ağva yerleri var
ava yerleri maymun eti yiyorlar
maymunları ormanda avlıyorlar ve etini
çok lezzetli buluyorlar ama Anneleri
avlanan yavrular Tabii ki Öksüz kalıyor
Bu kadınlar da onları bir bebek gibi
evlat ediniyorlar Üstelik onları aynı
bebekleri ile beraber yetiştirirken
Hatta ve hatta emziriyorlar
emzirmezlerse Çünkü kendilerini
öleceğini söylemeklere yani maymunlara
karşı bu kadar zalim olan bir kitlenin
ya da halkın yavrulara karşı bu kadar
ılımlı olması bana çok ilginç geliyor
mesela
kadınların da aynı şekilde Makyaj
yaparken gözlerini daha iri
göstermelerinin de nedenini Belki şimdi
biraz daha iyi anlıyor da olabiliriz
işin ilginç tarafı dikkat edin mutlaka
Çevrenizde vardır bebeksi ya da çocuksuz
olarak da sadece çocuklarda değil
yetişkinlerde de bazen bebeksi 100
özelliklerine çocuksu yüz özelliklerine
rastlayabiliyoruz bunlar aynı normal
bebekler gibi ya da çocuklar gibi gene
böyle geniş bir alma iri gözlere küçük
böyle buradan çeneye sahip olan ağza
sahip olan insanlar bazılarında ses de
gelişmemiş olabiliyor tüysüz oluyorlar
çoğunlukla falan buna tıpta Ne o teni
adı veriliyor yani
bebeksi özelliklerin çocuksu
özelliklerinin yetişkinlikte de ee devam
etmesine neutini adı veriliyor
bebeklerin ne kadar korunması olduğunu
zaten size anlatmıştım benzer şekilde bu
yetişkinler içinde İnsanların genel
böyle bir önyargıları var bilinç
altlarında Yani bu bebeksi yetişkinlerin
de ki burada Mesela bir mafya babası var
Amerika'dan bunların da benzer şekilde
kahramanlık yapamayacağına bilerek suç
işleyemeyeceklerine Efendim
saldırgan hareketler yapmayacaklarına
İnanılır ya da Bunlar mesela küfür
etseler sigara içseler tuhaf gelir
bizler bunları yadırganız Bu da aslında
yine bu doğuştan gelen tetiklememek
lazım bir tezahürü
Başka nerede görüyoruz mesela
yetişkinler arası
yaklaşımlarda görüyoruz özellikle
çiftler arasında bir şeyi kabul ettirmek
için böyle bebek gibi konuşmalar İşte bu
tarzdan yaklaşmalarda da aslında bunun
gene yansımalarını görüyoruz yani
gözlerini iri iri yapmış ağzını büzmüş
bebek gibi sesler çıkartan bir yetişkini
kim Hayır diyebilir ki
bununla yapılıyor
kur bu mahkeme salonları kuruluyor ve bu
mahkeme salonlarında
maskülen kişilerle bebeksi yüzlü kişiler
aynı suçla alakalı ifade veriyorlar daha
sonra gene kurgusal olarak oraya
konulmuş olan jüriden bunlarla alakalı
bir değerlendirme yapılmasını istiyor
bu jüri üyeleri normalde aslında ikisi
de aynı şekilde ifade vermesine rağmen
maskülen kişilerin kasıtlı suçu
işlediklerine yönünde ifade verirlerken
diğerlerinin bebeksiz özelliklerine
sahip olanların ise daha ziyade böyle
kasıtlı işlemedikleri taksirle
işledikleri konusunda bir yorumda
bulunuyorlar Yani bu Çok enteresan değil
mi bu büyüğü o zaman bile bozulmuyor her
şekilde böyle de devam ediyor Yani
yetişkinlikte bile bu büyüğü devam
ediyor
tosuncuk gibi Bazıları çocuksu
özelliklerini kullanarak kendilerini
zararsız gösteriyorlar ve bizi iliğimizi
sömürüyorlar deveyi havuduyla götürürken
Biz arkalarından şaşkın bakakalıyoruz
bebeksizdir seri katiller cezbederek
insanları hayatlarını elden alıyorlar ya
da toksik kişilikler kendilerini yine
zararsız göstererek hayatımıza
sızıyorlar ve bütün Hayat enerjimizi
aslında emiyorlar
daha da enteresan konular var aynı
durumda olmalarına rağmen bilinçaltında
Tabii gene Eğer ortaya çıkan durumlar
Bunlar fiziksel olarak uzun boylu
kişiler eşit durumda kısa boylulardan
daha fazla maaş alıyor ya da Fiziksel
anlamda çekici insanlar iş hayatında
daha başarılı daha aktif daha girişken
Ya da aile hayatında daha mutlu olarak
kabul ediliyor yapılan
değerlendirmelerde Fiziksel anlamda
çekici olan kişiler daha ikna edici
bulunuyor yeşil gözlü ve kumral kadınlar
daha ikna edici olduğu iddia ediliyor
hiç fiziksel anlamda çekici olmayan
insanlar hastanelerde daha ziyaret
ediliyor Fiziksel anlamda güzel olan
kadınlara bebekler daha uzun süreli
olarak bakıyorlar ya da işte
Salt uzun boyuyla işte ne bileyim
yakışıklı yüzüyle kumral bir adam
üzerinde ameliyat önlüğü ile olduğu
halde zengin ve güzel bir kadının
kalbini kazanıyor ve onun bütün hayatını
cehenneme çevirebiliyor bir başkası yine
cazibesini kullanarak Avrupa'nın 4
milyarından kadınları avlıyor ve bir
zengin hayatı yaşıyor Bunların hepsi
aslında bilimsel gerçekler
araştırmaların sonuçları
Beden dilini bilmek Beden dilini okumak
gerçekten çok önemli daha verimli bir
ilişki daha verimli bir iletişim
kurabilmek insanları anlatmadıklarını
dinlemek için Ama şu da var ki ta Koza
olduğumuz dönemden beynimize işlenen
bazı kodlamalar bizim bütün hayatımızı
yönlendirebiliyor bizim bütün hayatımıza
yön verebiliyor o yüzden o yüzden birisi
hiç beklenmedik bir anda tavus kuşu gibi
tüylerini kabartak abartaya yanınıza
geliyorsa ondan hemen uzaklaşın ya da
bir tosuncuk size doğru yaklaşmaya
başlamışsa hemen mazeret bile sunmadan
kaçıncının oradan yoksa bir sonraki
belgeselin mağduru size olabilirsiniz
ve şunu özellikle söylemek istiyorum ki
bir şey gerçek olamayacak kadar güzelse
zaten güzel gerçek değildir Çok teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]
Müsaade ederseniz Ahmet bahçıvan'dan bir
Koza şiirinden bir dörtlük Daha doğrusu
bir kısım okuyarak burada veda etmek
istiyorum
[Alkış]
ipeksi bir ölümün hışırtısıyla uyandım
tel tel çözülüp kozanızdan
yenik olanlar vurmak için yaşamaya
tanığımdır Nazlı Ilgın Boz Yavşan
yetişemedi sevgiler Umudun yılısına
gökyüzü Kuzgun Kuzgun sağılmadan
gidiyorum işte
güçsüz yazıları bürünmüş bir aile
beklemesin çocukluğu huysuzlanır yarım
kalan oyunlar
toparlamalıyım
eşyalara sinen yalnızlıkları
kimseler gelmeden istasyona Çok teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]